[Musique]
chaussures de sport espadrilles sni
creuse basket
peu importe comment on les appelle elles
sont partout et j'ai ce passionné elles
sont soigneusement rangés voilà par pas
loin de presque 300 perd 300 perd là
dans un petit peu partout il aux mêmes
s'écrit fit une partie de cette terrasse
pour construire sa caverne d'ali baba
j'ai fait construire ça pour pouvoir
enfin créer une petite pièce à
chaussures ça a été une longue
discussion avec ma femme et même le jour
de son mariage
il portait des espadrilles j'ai toujours
fonctionné au cou coeur peut être des
fois un petit matériel qui est différent
dessus ça peut être la couleur ça peut
être la forme ça peut être le nom comme
je disais basket préféré seul air max 1
je pense que je vais en avoir une
vingtaine d fois la semelle est
différente des fois il ya des
collaborations fille avec des artistes
mais que guerrier il eut aussi un
maniaque d'espadrilles il vient
justement de s'acheter trois nouvelles
pages sa collection en goût de douce
revanche et de nostalgie les entreprises
sont pas folles télé les modèles que
j'ai en général qui sont les plus
précieuses à mes yeux c'est des modèles
que ado on pouvait pas se permettre
couleurs chatoyantes matériaux choisis
design innovateur décidiez de sport sont
des pièces de collection
moi je suis comme un junior leveillé
déjà qu'ils sont vraiment passionnés qui
en font non seulement le patient vers un
métier parce que c'est un marché énorme
alimenté par une machine
multimilliardaire l'industrie disney que
ça représente 80 milliards de dollars
et là dessus il ya six milliards qu'ils
sont dans la revente et on dit que d'ici
quelques années on va passer à 30
milliards en revente donc ses claques
sont là pour rester
quelle seconde en ligne sur des sites
spécialisés chez les plus prestigieuses
au compteur
dans les boutiques ou le lancement de
certaines pertes d'exception attire des
foules prête à faire la file durant des
heures pour mettre la main sur le saint
graal et on peut penser directement à la
easy la toute première easy de kanye
west qui a été vendu à 1.8 millions de
dollars avec les prix qui s'envolent
ceux qui ont acheté la bonne paire est
pur moment ont pris une longueur
d'avancé les jordan quatre semaines ce
que j'ai pu avoir en 2016 je le
revendrai jamais cela ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal